hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whack your computer the
final game in the whack it series I'm
still being held captive in the grub
space or I mean my Internet's out at
home and I'm here totally voluntarily
and I don't keep looking at that window
because I think that a grump is gonna
come after me it's five nights at grumps
if you know what I mean but this is the
last in the wack anything series so you
can get done with your wackiness and be
totally stress relieved after this last
adventure where we beat up a safe little
computer and don't have to murder
anybody well they're probably gonna be
murder of some sort but there's here we
go this is made by the original guy that
did whack your boss so in this one it
actually has the same charm and style as
like whack your boss and whack your ex
whereas the other one were made by other
people what am i doin I missed something
important didn't I oh I get it
okay he's about to dictate and he wants
to get his dictation on with his
assistant but his computer's being all
dickish so okay wait I haven't even
clicked a button yet I am NOT ready
there's something very charming about
this guy's style it's just very elegant
and ready to go oh it looped through
entirely ooh
so many options just please whack it
hard with swards oh well you probably
could have just stabbed yourself through
your eyes there I thought like wait what
when did she get a leopard sprint what
was she wait a minute what the hell
happened why would she fall in love with
him when he died stop his own computer
oh I thought they were all ah okay I
thought they were gonna get it all on
freaky-deaky jungle style because he had
the leopard print is it like George's
the jungle is nevermind what what why do
you love him for that that doesn't make
any celeb print why is this your fantasy
Manhattan all right whatever fine what
else do we have fun I love how he
instantly turned super saiyan so angry
wait a minute seems like might be a bad
idea okay man what's with you
well did those missiles blow your
clothes off do I have to click on your
nippy nips they look like a pair of eyes
just staring dead staring into your soul
his fantasy is filled with the empty
pits of his heart anyway continue wait
from this horrid fantasy and move on to
something of a bit more quality what
else do we have what about this Picasso
Oh once we're not old e-trade up but
somehow she'll love you for this though
it's the happy I'm alive and didn't get
blown away with a bazooka oh you crazy
crazy son of a [ __ ] what are you gonna
do next
oh no no fishy or no you gotta save a
defeat sheet and then promptly kill your
leg well okay is it dead please tell me
this Kenneth oh it's not that just
exploded for some damn reason she's not
wearing any leopard print so I guess
that's good lady is there anything on
your body that I could use with which to
kill this computer or whatever this is
okay all right I'm okay with the bazooka
in the air strike but why do you have a
sticker gun
I'm not gonna come and how illogical
that is because none of this is very
logical
I suppose that in all honesty this makes
total sense considering that in whack
your boss you can't possibly be killing
him in all those ways you would be
horribly arrested yep yeah she likes to
live on the edge
for some reason going off in this game
oh there is oh oh it's true love lady
please help a little bit Wow I wouldn't
be surprised if there's another reason
in this game where her head came clean
off and sailed through that not they're
in love perfect love the ultimate love
killing electronics love I don't approve
of it this kind of love it's unnatural I
tell ya about the modern art well I
don't much care for modern art anyway oh
I thought you were George of the jungle
come on I'm very impressed bring it to
it love fight some god damn recent what
about they come here to herself well how
about this one on for size
another bazooka to chainsaw
another good oh I thought it was gonna
come I thought he was gonna be split in
half
well I can't swim laughs this is much
too happy I'm I was expecting this to be
happy I didn't expect there to be lots
of life but now I'm just disappointed
that there aren't gallons of blood
spewing Kill Bill style everywhere well
Oh shoo shoo ha ha oh that's what you
did
to curb stomp everybody else now you're
curb stomping you can be my weapon what
did I win a trip into the fantasy world
were chic why is the computer still
there none of this makes any sense
all my world is throne of heart before
me ah chaos is all that is understood
what is going on
I'm not stress relieved I'm more
stressed ah
so anyway that is the end of the whack
it series there are no more watch games
as far as I know so I can close this
book and end that chapter for good
unless it comes another one and you want
to see another violent endeavor
that's it for now so thank you all so
much for watching check out the other
games I played about whacking things in
the description below or in the
annotations over there thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]